التوجه نحو صناديق الاقتراع تلك ليس عمليه
سياسيه ديمقراطيه فقط بلته مطلبا شعبيا في
تايوان وسطه تصاعدي العداء مع الصين بدء
الناخبون في تايوان التصويت في انتخابات
المحليه وصفتها الرئيس
بانها رساله قويه الى العالم مفادها ان
الجزيره مصممه على الدفاع عن ديمقراطتها
في مواجهه التوتر مع الجاره الصين
الديمقراطيه ولهذا اموال ان كل المواطنين
في بلدنا سيذهبون للادلاء باصواتهم لتقرير
مستقبل بلدنا تتهم تايوان بكين بانها
تحاولوا بشكل متكرر التاثر على نتائج
انتخاباتها سواء من خلال حملات التظليل
عبر الانترنت او التهديدات العسكريه
الصريحه الا ان وزير الخارجيه تايوانيه
جوزه فوق اكد تراجعا تدخل الصين قبل
انتخابات المحليه بتايوان وعسى ذلك
لانشغال الصين بمشاكلها الداخليه
بتايوان وذلك ربما بسبب مشاكلها الداخليه
وجهودها لتحسين صورتها الدوليه
ليس خارجيا بل داخليا فردا على مزاعم
التدخل الصين في الانتخابات بتايوان اتهم
الحزب الديمقراطي والتقدميه الحاكم في
تايوان السلطات في تايبيه بمحاوله تحقيق
مكاسب السياسيه بتضخيم التهديد من الصين
وكان حزب المعارضه الرئيسي في تايوان
الكومنتانج اكتسح الانتخابات المحليه في
عام 2018 واتهم رئيسه البلاد بالافراط في
المواجهه مع الصين حزب الكومنتات عرف
بتفضيله تقليديا تعزيز العلاقات مع الصين
رغم انه ينفي بشده ان يكون مؤيدا بالتين
لكن افعاله تناقض اقواله ففي اغسطس الماضي
ارسل الحزب المعارض التايوانيه وفدا الى
الصين رغم التمديد الداخلي ووسط التوتر
المستمر بسبب المناورات العسكريه التي
يقوم بها الجيش الصيني في المنطقه روان
حمزه العربيه